[Music]
foreign
[Music]
all of you in the best of health and
iman and you're all doing fine you're
tuning into another episode
of ask the chef we are here with our
shaykh
inshallah today's discussion is going to
be about sheikh basically
there's a girl or a boy it can happen
with both cases they're growing up
trying to be a good muslim
but they start discovering these new
tendencies yeah
they are feeling attracted to the same
gender the girl starts feeling attracted
to girls the boy starts feeling
attracted to boys
yeah he feels like he's turning bisexual
or gay
can that person still be a muslim is
that person instantly a cafe or what
happens
yeah okay yeah this is yeah
this is a very interesting question and
i think
it takes time to to address it from all
angles
yes uh however i will just maybe give a
taster for
our brothers and sisters yeah
about this issue now see
i've been dealing with this case a lot
okay for in fact the last in the last
few months i had the three cases
yeah a young boy he feels that he's a
gay uh
a young sister she feels that she's
libyan
lesbian she's attracted uh one of the
recent cases
a young boy he came actually with his
father and he feels that he
is a gay yeah yeah
i asked him number of questions i said
to him
one key question i want the brothers and
sisters to ask themselves this question
yeah see in the beginning when
when the young boy he is mixing with
young boys he might be emotional same
thing with sisters with sisters even it
is
bigger they become emotional
in generally speaking at the the after
puberty
they are emotional emotional they want
they want to be loved and they want to
love someone okay
yeah and when for example
boys or girls mixing with each other
they might find that they are
close one sister might find that she is
close to
a particular sister yeah and the boy
feels that he is close to a particular
boy
yeah even practicing people they might
feel that they are close to each other
they start what
to do half of the quran together
just about it they feel okay that they
do have together
then the shaytan comes to them and tells
them that oh
listen before you go to bed send salam
to the other person
after you go to bed send salam to the
other person
yeah it check whether he has said his
car she has said the ad car
etc etc so they developed a relationship
like this
okay slowly slowly as they as i said the
shaytan is involving
uh is involved and then the shaytan says
oh
use what certain words like
oh so i missed you okay
i need to see you okay okay yeah
and then they start using innocently
this kind of language not in the wrong
way
not in their own body that way so they
become
even more attached to each other okay
okay
slowly slowly oh the
each side might feel that he can't
stay for long time away from seeing the
other side
okay okay yeah
and then oh i i could not
sleep because i could not see you for
the last two three days
you know yeah then the relationship
develops slowly slowly
until when they come next to each other
yeah
they would like to sit okay next to each
other
they would like to hold in hand they
would like to
have some physical contact okay
yeah then slowly slowly the shaytan
might come to them
with some bad ideas such as let me be
open with brothers and sisters yeah
yeah this is young boys and young girls
told me this
yeah they like to spend
time together in secluded no one with
them
okay they feel happy together yeah
together alone then they might like when
they stay together they might like hold
hands
for long time yeah sometimes they like
that the skin will be next to the skin
okay and what may happen as it happened
with some boys some girls
they were sleeping
next to each other not in a bad way but
they
feel kind of love happiness
yeah and then after some time they the
shaytan comes to them and tells them
take off your clothes the skin too
next to the skin so it's a buildup okay
so it is a build-up now
i say to them okay because now i have
experience so
that's why i described talking not
happening
okay to me yeah yeah so
i can explain this and it is very
important for
those brothers or sisters who feel that
they have this
to feel that the person in front of them
understand this
so you've seen some cases where it's
been like what you said
most of the cases are like this okay so
it's not actually sexual attraction yeah
yeah this is the point so it might
turn to be a sexual attraction it might
okay
it can happen okay now i ask those
boys and girls i said to them are you
attracted to
for example the boy are you attracted to
boys from the same boys
yeah the sister i asked her are you
attracted to
all girls or just that particular one
and i think in
in all cases i don't remember a single
case where
the person says i am attracted to all
boys yeah or most of the boys
or maybe let me be open so
to the handsome boys yeah or the sister
i'm attracted to
so and so girls no it is that particular
or or for example boys with this feature
or girls
[Music]
okay yeah and then because of what we
read in the media about homosexuality
and it is a natural thing
and labeling yeah
the issue of labeling that okay the
person who is attracted to
the same gender yeah it is put like this
and so he it is a natural for him to be
attracted to the same gender it is
natural for her to be attracted to the
same gender this is called homosexuality
okay yeah so they start labeling
themselves like this
and they start to internalize
this and then the problem becomes bigger
we'll stop here we will continue in the
coming
episode this is that as i said it's just
a taster
okay inshallah inshallah so guys i want
to thank you for watching basically this
is part one
addressing this topic inshallah stay
tuned for part two
and yeah we're gonna get into that
inshallah if you have any more questions
for shaykh
them email us at the email below take
care of yourselves
salam alaikum
he feels that he's a gay a young sister
she feels that she's libyan lesbian she
is attracted
again as well you know in order to deal
with this
uh the young boy okay that i dealt with
him
recently and in fact i dealt with so
many
young boys like this
hey give me one
[Music]
thanks honey subscribe